carrusel de las artes maría carolina
piña
[Música]
un gusto saludarles nuevamente desde
varias bienvenidos a este programa en el
que les proponemos a evadirnos a través
de la cultura y de las artes estos son
los temas que les presentamos el día de
hoy
descubriremos la obra casi desconocida
de fonz o ha visto viaje pintor y
caricaturista que viajó a territorios
remotos para plasmar imponentes paisajes
en sus pinturas conoceremos a la
cantante sílvia pérez cruz ganadora en
francia- del premio lumière a la mejor
música original por su trabajo en la
película josep los cines siguen cerrados
en francia pero las películas francesas
han seguido viajando y cosechando éxitos
en todos los rincones del planeta y a
pocos días del día de los enamorados
cómo se le canta al amor en la canción
francesa contemporánea se lo contamos en
nuestra crónica musical
[Música]
comenzamos este carrusel de las artes
descubriendo la obra de un pintor
francés excepcional con sua
quizá sea la primera vez que escuchan
este nombre pues tristemente fue
olvidado con el paso del tiempo sin
embargo hoy se reconoce su gran talento
y humor viaja exploro géneros muy
diversos y plasmó sus viajes por el
mundo en lienzos imponentes y llenos de
realismo
el nombre de fonz o cristo viaje se
perdió en los meandros de la historia
sin embargo este pintor y caricaturista
francés del siglo 19 legó a la
posteridad paisajes de una gran belleza
y escenas exóticas pero fue gracias a su
sentido del humor y de la observación
que debutó en los círculos artísticos
[Música]
bear fue un autodidacta cuando se
instaló en parís se dedicó a introducir
la caricatura en pintura pintó escenas
cómicas que lo hicieron famoso entre
1830 a 1840 gente se agolpaba en los
salones para ver y reírse con los
cuadros de viaje eran escenas de la vida
cotidiana escenas burlescas tenía mucho
éxito aunque los críticos no soportaban
que alguien quisiera reducir a la
pintura y ponerla al nivel de la
caricatura para ellos tanta trivialidad
era nefasta para la pintura
abc la canción a un gigante afecto quien
viene fast
[Música]
y también pintó cuadros grandiosos del
polo norte luego de haber participado en
dos expediciones científicas a la isla
de spitsbergen y a laponia en 1839 20
años después un viaje a brasil le
inspiró una serie de lienzos sobre la
selva y sus indígenas con caviar le
interesaba pintar lo desconocido los
grandes témpanos de hielo del polo norte
o la inhóspita selva amazónica son la
materia para grandes composiciones en
las que biar pone de relieve el paisaje
y los habitantes locales bear tenía un
objetivo científico buscó restituir en
su pintura lo que vio en esos lugares
remotos esos paisajes asombraron al
público eran tan reales que los críticos
pensaban que no podía ser así y es
irónico que lo que hoy en día nos llama
más la atención fue lo que en su época
suscitó las mayores reservas
[Música]
en 1848 pintó la abolición de la
esclavitud en las colonias francesas un
cuadro que todavía hoy se utiliza en los
manuales escolares pero porque a pesar
de su talento ni su nombre ni su obra
trascendieron por un lado la pintura de
género perdió interés el humor en 1870
no era el mismo que en 1830 los códigos
sociales habían evolucionado y por el
otro sus pinturas de viajes cayeron en
el olvido a medida que el hombre fue
descubriendo nuevos territorios
biar fue entonces olvidado y murió solo
y aislado en 1880 vacías y llorando
y una película de animación
franco-española rescata la historia de
josep bartolí un dibujante republicano
que se exilió en francia durante el
franquismo esta cinta fue distinguida
por la crítica extranjera aquí en
francia y en carrusel de las artes
pudimos conversar con la autora de la
banda original de esta película la
cantante sílvia pérez cruz
[Música]
ni yo ni que el curso
josep cuenta en dibujos la historia de
ellos de bártoli un dibujante y
republicano español quien se exilió en
francia en 1939 huyendo del franquismo
pero su anhelo de libertad fue frenado
brutalmente los campos de concentración
franceses donde miles de españoles
sufrieron hambre enfermedades y malos
tratos en la que ustedes pararon con
muchas ganas
podemos
no
[Música]
dios
esta conmovedora película del dibujante
francés hoja le ganó los premios lumière
de la prensa extranjera en francia al
mejor largometraje de animación y a la
mejor música original compuesta por la
cantante sílvia pérez cruz quien trabajó
mano a mano con ojal
mientras el dibujo tomaba forma
intenté trabajarlo como si yo fuera
pintora también a través del sonido y me
creé mi propia paleta de texturas
musicales que representaban pues desde
la arena y el viento del campo de
concentración la libertad fuese el piano
luego allí una canción
veamos qué va resonando durante toda la
película y así un trabajo de realmente
muy muy paralelo de aprender y que haya
un momento que no sabes dónde empieza y
dónde termina la música y el dibujo nos
hemos inspirado y respetado mucho
mutuamente
[Música]
más tienen
no sé
tiene
y ya que hablábamos de cine en francia
las salas siguen cerradas y las nuevas
producciones paralizadas debido a la
epidemia de coronavirus pero a pesar de
esta crisis sanitaria las cintas
francesas siguen viajando por el mundo
algunas con un éxito rotundo nos amplía
melissa barra
no son amigos y sonrisas
con la pandemia a la baja de estrenos en
hollywood dio un nuevo brillo al cine
francés varias películas le dieron la
vuelta al mundo en 2020 porque desde la
revisión fue en español retrato de una
mujer en llamas ha sido vista por un
millón y medio de espectadores en 40
países desde su estreno
este look salvaje
seleccionada para la palma de oro y
ganadora del mejor guión en el festival
de cannes 2019 la cinta fue nominada
también en varios festivales extranjeros
incluidos los bafta y los golden globes
relata la historia de amor entre una
pintora y su modelo en la francia del
siglo 18
quiero un éxito
y otro gran éxito francés en cannes y en
las taquillas del mundo fue los
miserables de la xli un drama sobre las
violencias policiales y las
discriminaciones en el suburbio popular
de mujer media al este de parís que
llegó a los cines en 46 países y fue
nominado al oscar de la mejor película
extranjera
el oficial y el espía el ex rector de
roman polanski generó 700 mil entradas
en 2020 y también una de las polémicas
más estruendosas del año al ser
distinguido como el premio césar al
mejor director a pesar de las
acusaciones en su contra por abuso de
menores
[Música]
la dragón no en español mamá maría se
estrena en septiembre y se destacó en
cientos de salas europeas
anamar han de un pescado nada más
sentirse las limpias
isabel hiper quien fue catalogada como
la mejor actriz del siglo 21 por el 'new
york times' interpreta a una traductora
de árabe contratada por la policía y que
decide meterse en el negocio de las
drogas en alemania la consideran la
comedia del año
[Música]
qué serían las canciones sin el amor
vamos a repasar a ya mismo algunas de
las canciones francesas actuales que le
rinden homenaje a ese sentimiento que ha
inspirado a tantos artistas y ya para
hablar de eso está con nosotros natale
olivares hola natalia hola maría de
carolina y uno de los que se inspiró en
el amor es el rapero dinos es conocido
por la técnica que tiene pero también
por la profundidad de sus textos él
creció en los suburbios parisinos y
canta esta canción el sitio
[Música]
es un tema sobre el amor desilusionado
incluso fue escrito con figuras
literarias
recordemos que dinos en su último álbum
histaminas le rinde homenaje a un gran
autor msd padre de la negritud y el amor
también inspirado a una joven cantante
camelia jordan a quien también es
militante
contra la violencia de género y contra
el racismo y ella tiene una canción
sobre el amor en su último disco y esta
canción se llama cylons como para salir
del silencio simplemente
[Música]
sí
bien
si no es una canción de amor pero
también considerada como una canción de
crítica a los que hablan demasiado en
los medios de comunicación y también en
las redes sociales
natalie con esta crisis sanitaria el
amor se ha vuelto más difícil que cuando
gozábamos de plena libertad sin embargo
el cantante con comalada también le
dedica una canción a las mujeres y al
amor exactamente le dedica en una
canción pero también en todo su álbum
que se llama meta en un homenaje a las
mujeres y que ha hecho que está hecho
con simplemente puros tubos con mujeres
y medio tema es un ejemplo que canta con
que a mí la luz
ese famoso monje fue noble el final
[Música]
pero tenemos una balada compuesta por
ella porque amigo y lucha esta cantante
y también humorista que dice haberla
escrita durante una relación intensa de
amor y también dice no haberla podido
terminar nunca
la canción manny con este tema medio
temático con coma lado vamos a despedir
con mucho amor este carrusel de las
artes muchísimas gracias por su amable
atención ya saben que nos pueden seguir
en rf y fans 24 y nuestras redes
sociales cuídense mucho y hasta la
próxima
fácil
yo te invitamos al medidor del sistema
normal
[Música]
efectuando